Now back when the Nintendo 64 was still in prototype, the execs over at
Nintendo did a little bit of tricky marketing. They brought in a bunch of
reporters, put them in a room, they pretty much had a screen rendering a little
character on it, and a little interesting black box in front of them. Now the
black box was completely hidden. All the reporters could do was stick their
hands inside and fumble around with the controller that was in it. After a
while of playing with these things, one of the reporters said that the
controllers were so revolutionary, it was like his thoughts were being extended
right into the game, which is a great case and point. If you get the controls
right, the world plays along with you. Get it wrong and, well I'm pretty sure
you can guess what happens then.